all right let's agree on some
definitions or let's get them out of the
way so perhaps lee why don't you define
i know this is highly contentious but
why don't you define what life is and if
you can't define it then why can't you
define it and then also intelligence so
life and intelligence and then brian
add to that or tear it down
yeah yeah please tear it down so there's
more definitions of life than there are
life forms on earth thinking about it
which will give you some but i'll give
you the standard nasa definition and
i'll give you a slightly easier one
which will also blow your mind so nasa
kind of got a committee and got a lot of
really smart people together and really
you know said well okay look what are we
kind of looking for
and i'm going to get this wrong because
i i i don't know if i
wrote but it's roughly saying that life
is a
self um reproducing or a sustaining
um um
evolutionary chemical system capable of
darwinian evolution i think i've almost
got it in a line and that's there's a
lot of things in there because it's
saying has to be self-sustaining there's
replication and there's darwinian
evolution there's kind of a lot of terms
and the thing for that is that you have
to then get almost like the legislature
out to say you know do you qualify to be
a life form you know are you replicating
okay maybe are you metabolizing and then
you get people saying oh but fire fire
fire kind of does that why is fire not
alive and you get all trapped into
circles and people say are viruses are
they alive so i'm going to give you um
the kind of cronin
definition but actually is the probably
more like the walker definition or the
cronin walker definition and i'm i'm
collaborating with a a colleague at asu
sarah walker um who really has inspired
a lot of this and we kind of we've been
developing theory but i'll come to that
later but what i'm going to say and this
is for you the people listening
the
living systems i don't know what they
are exactly they're kind of like a bit
although they're material there's some
weird stuff but what do living systems
uniquely do that no other systems do
they create
complex objects okay
in abundance that couldn't form randomly
so be it this 3d printed tesseract which
i made on my 3d printer
um this nice um
fenix
solar watch which are the lights coming
on at the back so it's all function and
my mouse and my my body and with the
complex objects that um they just
couldn't randomly form now we can define
complexity in a minute but i'm going to
give you kind of one other thing
this thing or kind of says that this is
alive and it kind of is which will blow
your mind this is this is alive
or this is evidence of life and then
people say ah a virus is alive
and the answer is yes
viruses are produced by
um
evolutionary systems with biology and
that viruses could not
exist without the chain of events which
connects all of us
right back to that origin of life on
earth so i guess i'm saying nasa
definition for some of the aficionados
you know replication metabolism
darwinian evolution
but i would say okay that's really hard
tick box tick box why not look for
things that do complex things that we
wouldn't expect
and so that's life
to one degree then intelligence kind of
builds on that because clearly
this was not evolved in in the desert
this required human beings to invent
you know
lithography a turing machine electricity
i mean i am so proud of humanity it
might seem a bit like a little bit kind
of um you know
weird but how much creativity went into
making this silly little watch there's a
solar cell in here there are leds
there's a microprocessor there's
lithographic defined memory and there's
refined titanium i was feeling rich when
i bought when i bought this one i wanted
a light watch on my list so there's all
this cool stuff that we've done and this
clearly is evidence and i'm going to use
this term and i don't like using it but
i'm going to use it in the way that i
mean it and i'm sure brian will and you
will cut me down if you think i'm being
uh ambiguous this is a result of
intelligent design
and what i mean a human being building
abstractions in their head were able to
leap beyond the confines of evolution
able to think about stuff and
conceptualize not having to die trying
it out and they made the watch so
all the way back definition of life
evolution chemistry
nasa my definition stuff
things that make complex things you
couldn't er in abundance with lots of
copy numbers that you wouldn't find
um ordinarily say on the moon on the
mars and
intelligent life can make objects are
even more intricate so you have three
epochs you have the random epoch just
laws of physics doing their cool stuff
the biological epoch the distribution of
objects in that in their narrows a bit
and then
and then technology and intelligence
produces a delta function the number of
transistors in here that have no
variation almost perfect is a staggering
and that's kind of long-winded but i
think i just wanted to get that out it's
quite precise and will get people
watching and listening to think really
like oh my gosh
this cup is evidence of billion years of
life because of no potter no discovery
of no clay no cup
just imagine how many this this lineage
this trajectory this object this is
actually made in beijing there's some
lovely pictures on here
this is evidence of billions of years of
progress i'll stop there
brian what are your comments on that
well yeah you know of course with the
definition as maybe one could say
flexible as
all that could you know be said to
entail of course there's there's uh it's
hard to disagree
i was preferring to think about things
you know there was a decision you you
both are not of the united states in
origin uh but there was a famous supreme
court case in the 50s i think where the
court was asked to describe what is
pornographic and the upshot was that you
know it when you see it and i think you
know we can we can kind of uh you know
debate about things that we know for
sure aren't alive and we can debate
about things that we could all say are
alive and i think leads on to something
that there may be a deep and
maybe unassailable interplay between the
uh notion of the conscious being that's
defining life
and the order and structure uh by which
he or she ascribes that feature to be
indicative of a biological process
normally what i hear is well life it
depends and even what is consciousness
it depends and as you know kurt there
are people that believe you know the
quarks in the cup that lee was holding
up are a lot or have consciousness you
know the pan psychist format i don't
know if lee believes that or not uh but
uh but i i would suspect not yes he's
shaking his head so i think uh what i
think is important is that we all sort
of can recognize the boundary cases um
as not or or yes certainly affirming to
be of life and it's kind of like you
know these debates about you know uh
like think about abortion abortion is
really controversial here in america um
nobody would say before your parents met
each other uh that you were an organism
you were a baby and nobody would say
after you know 10 months out of the womb
that you're not a living being so it's
in the it's in the superposition the
schrodinger state where it can be is it
alive is it that's where the ambiguity
comes in and the human brain as lee
knows and you know too lee
kurt
hates ambiguity we force patterns on top
of things the ambiguity bias is a
well-known psychological affair so the
question is not are the edge cases alive
um
but are the you know how do we how do we
parse and split with granularity that's
sufficient to provide the satisfaction
morally and and intellectually that
we're actually making progress so i like
that lee began or you know uh originally
he mentioned the drake equation and we
should we should actually go through
that and what that entails because i
think in that realm my field not me
specifically i don't study the origin of
life or technology et cetera um it has
has brought the most to bear
the field of astrophysics again not what
i do but the many terms in the drake
equation have been reduced in their
uncertainty has come from astrophysics
not from chemistry not from biology etc
you know from discoveries that have been
made by my colleagues not by me again so
i think what's what's important is that
we we all can first agree on the
baseline definitions on the pitch uh
which is that you know living things we
we have some vague notion of what living
things are and i think the only thing i
was a little discouraged and what lee
said originally was he doesn't want to
talk about the origin of life and i feel
like all these things are kind of
interrelated there are classic chicken
or egg type problems you know and and i
think
life chemistry etc has has a great deal
to say and i'm i'm doubly surprised
because in leigh's phenomenal ted talk
from 2011 september 9th 2011 my 40th
birthday uh he goes on and tells chris
anderson in front of a live audience
that within two years he's going to be
able to make life in his laboratory and
i don't think necessarily that you would
claim that to be a successful bet at
this point lee but i'd love to know what
what is and i'm not criticizing you
merely bringing up the fact that there
is a tendency mostly in my field to have
things like the god equation the god
particle uh the mind of god and the god
all these things the hype that we have
in the field of cosmology kurt is
unparalleled
and i worry that if we um if we don't
avoid that in kind of the essence of
describing the origin of life evolution
of life aliens ufos all the things we're
going to talk about today i hope we will
because it's so fascinating and it's
driven me since i was a kid um
nevertheless there is a tendency and a
propensity for us to believe what we
want to believe and maybe put things in
the file drawer that we find discrepant
and so uh i would just say i think it is
important that we talk about the origin
of life i think that's a crucial
question and i think there's no one
better on earth to talk to than lee